so if america's darkest days lie ahead
how are we going to get through those
dark days
a lot of people have been out of work at
this point what 11 months
congress sent them 1200 maybe people got
1200
earlier doesn't get you very far well
now
we've got a wonderful major important
stimulus
covid relief plan congress is going to
send
some of you 600
for being out of work 11 months and
nancy pelosi says this is
very significant we also have in the
legislation
direct payments which were not in the
republican bill
to america's working families i would
like them
bigger but they are uh significant
and they will be going out soon
very significant now look pelosi she
wishes it could have been bigger
how big is this relief bill going to be
it's going to be like a trillion dollars
and another
trillion some odd dollars added on with
all sorts of foreign aid and all sorts
of payoffs to political cronies
but you know unfortunately all congress
could find with 600 measly dollars
for the inconvenience of destroying your
livelihoods for the past
year significant
is 600 significant i don't think so when
we're talking about keeping you out of
work for an entire year
nancy pelosi wouldn't think so too if it
were politically convenient for her to
say what you really thought because i
remember two years ago
do you remember this two years ago
president trump passes this
tax bill this tax reform bill and nancy
pelosi comes out
and says this bill is terrible you know
it gives
tax breaks to zillionaires and
corporations
and that wasn't true the tax bill also
gave about a thousand dollars in relief
to individuals and you know nancy pelosi
thousand dollars who needs a thousand
dollars
that ain't nothing but crumbs the in
terms of the
bonus that corporate america received
versus the
crumbs that they are giving to workers
to kind of
put the schmooze on is so pathetic it's
so pathetic
it is pathetic i hate to say that i
agree with nancy pelosi two years ago
but i do agree with nancy pelosi two
years ago by the way
at the time in terms of a tax bill
that's a pretty good break
but we are now in this unprecedented
moment
where these politicians for their own
political ends
can't forget it was an election year
decided to shut down the country
destroy people's lives even before the
the coronavirus gave them the excuse to
do this
you had prominent left-wingers guys like
bill maher who said we need a recession
we need a recession i know it'll hurt
some people but we need it because
that's the only way that we can get
trump out
so and and frankly the left did more
than give us a recession
the left shut down the country
for a year and then the way they're
going to make it up to us
is 600 no
i can't tell you how many letters i've
seen
tweets posts all over the place from
people who say i lost my savings
i lost my business my family is really
struggling
and you can take your six hundred
dollars and shove it i don't want it
it's just not enough i would i would
much rather and i think
a lot of people feel this way not get
the six hundred dollars
right now even if even if a lot of
people need it and i know a lot of
people who need it
better to knock at the six hundred
dollars than to go along with this
outrageous offensive bill that is going
to in debt
generations after us first of all
because of these
ridiculous spending projects and that is
frankly such a slap in the face
these these uh elite politicians in dc
members of both parties more than
democrats but some republicans too
saying oh the other the plebeians
they're they're they're complaining
again give them 600
600 what does that come out it comes out
to about six bucks a day
since they shut down the country that's
adding it on to the 1200
that we got early on six bucks a day not
worth it not going to make a difference
they need to veto this bill very
fortunately president trump has
intimated that he will veto this bill
[Music]
you